[Music]
[Music]
it's so trippy to me because it kind of
hit me today like i hit
at the 25-year mark before i turn 40
which is wild and it's also wild that
all of these women are close to my age
or if not the same age and it's really
hard for me to wrap my mind around to be
honest but it's so sweet and every one
of these women here tonight has touched
me
just by being here and by sharing their
stories with me like
you know you never know how your life is
being used and
clearly like i mean there are five
um examples of how i was used as a kid
like to to prove to these other women
that they
they have a dream and that they can
achieve that and so yeah it's cool it's
um like i said hard for me to take in
but when i stop for a moment and do it's
um it's very sweet see how far i can go
it's nice to come together as women who
have experienced a lot of the same
things but also look at her and just
realize she navigated so much publicly
from a young age
[Music]
if you were going to put me in a box
like and tell me no i was going to do
the complete opposite um i just you
can't put a 14 or really i was i mean i
was 11 when i saw my deal you can't put
a child in this business and be like be
that forever
one of the really special things about
land is that she started in that real
classic place and then we got to take we
have gotten to take a musical journey
with her where she evolved
and
changed and grew
just the little bit that i've had in the
last five years of navigating i can't
imagine doing that as a child and so i
think i just have a lot of grace for her
and respect for the way that she has
transcended so many years of and and
different
trends
and is still just
classic i feel like she's a classic
we've had her since she was 13 14 years
old so we've gotten to see
so many different
shapes to what she does and she's so
talented
that she can sing so many things it just
it has blown my mind
learning these songs of hers that you
feel like you know and then you sing
them and you're like man that is so hard
she makes it sound easy
for me when i look at music
it's just an expression of what i'm
feeling at the time and so
there was never any boundaries with that
so like you can't label that